[Applause]
[Music]
wait a minute well welcome everyone to
the gathering here today entitled Trump
ethics in the law I should note that
this panel discussion as a result will
end approximately three days 11 hours
[Laughter]
I'm Dave Leventhal I'm the senior
political reporter for the Center for
Public Integrity a non-profit
investigative news organization in
Washington DC and we have quite an
all-star panel with us today they almost
need no introduction however we will
introduce them anyway and starting to my
right is somebody who Donald Trump
probably knows quite well and that is
Walter Shaab who up until July mid-july
this year was the director of the office
of government ethics and is now with the
campaign Legal Center another nonprofit
in Washington DC
next up is Matthew Miller Matthew is
currently a partner at Via nuovo a
strategic advisory firm for brand policy
and crisis issues he previously led the
Department of Justice's communications
team under President Barack Obama and
was the spokesperson for Eric Holder
going down the line mr. Richard painter
who is a chief ethics lawyer for George
W Bush from 2005 to 2007 and most
recently has been at your the
co-chairperson am i correct and the vice
chair vice chairperson of citizens for
responsibility for responsibility and
ethics in Washington and is also a law
professor in Minnesota
and to my extreme left
I guess one could say appearing on this
extreme left for the first time his
judge Ken Starr who has a resume that we
could go on and on the highlights of
course Solicitor General of the United
States a federal judge the Chancellor
and president of Baylor University and
perhaps best known by all of us who
around in the 1990s as independent
counsel investigating at the time
President Bill Clinton thank you
[Applause]
so the topic of course is Donald Trump
here we are today in 2017 and i'd like
you all first to weigh in on this one
question for the course of one year is
Donald Trump's presidency the most
ethically challenged presidency in your
estimation and if not whose was I will
start with well well it's a tough
question to answer because I don't know
much about the tenure of Millard
Fillmore but at least going back to the
ethics and government acts passage I
don't think we've had anything that
would even come close to rivaling the
kind of ethical concerns that we're
seeing now well somebody who was born in
Millard Fillmore Hospital in Buffalo New
York I you know I did my research
research excellent map I'm gonna give
the start with the same disclaimer as
Walt you know that might disappoint my
former UT professors of the American
presidency I don't remember everyone
dating back into the 19th century but I
think if you look at modern history
we've never before obviously had a
president who was invest under
investigation for obstruction of justice
for acts that started seven days after
he took office we've never had a
president who's been under investigation
for actions that happened during his
campaign this soon into his first year
in office and of course we can talk
about the President and will to no end
but you also have to look at his cabinet
and one of the things I think actual
challenges of you know what reporters
have covering Washington is all of those
of us who care what happens in
Washington have is is Donald Trump sucks
up so much attention we miss a lot of
the other kind of institutional
corruption that's happening across
Washington look at the you know the last
month the revelations about the Treasury
Secretary flying on government planes
and his predecessors didn't the HHS
secretary flying on government planes
when none of his predecessors did so I
think you know when you look at the way
this administration vetted people
appointed people who have never served
in government before which is fine in
theory their quality upstanding people
nor the advice of people like Walt about
how to set up appointees free from from
conflicts of interest I think you're
gonna see you know we've obviously seen
a huge ethical challenge to start the
administration and I think there are
problems lying in wait that we're only
going to begin to find about out about
in the next few months Richard well I
told my twelve-year-old son the other
day that when I was 12 years old my eyes
were glued to the television watching
the Watergate hearings and I still
remember senator Sam Ervin oh boy he
didn't want to mess with him you know
back in those days they had oversight in
Congress and the President Nixon went
down but I've got to say that I think
President Nixon has really been given a
raw deal look okay maybe it wasn't crook
but at least it was our crook that
Watergate job third-rate burglary a
bunch of buffoons didn't know what
they'd even know what to do with the
masking tape or whatever
okay the break-in to the Democratic
Party headquarters this time is a high
tech job done by a bunch of ex-kgb
agents and of course there was no
collaboration just a meeting at the
Trump Tower with the top brass of his
campaign a bunch of Russians
[Applause]
I think the President Nixon has moved on
down at the number two spot ethics
issues a very rough start and I can't
think of a parallel your question does
remind me that President Reagan's first
national security adviser what's gone
almost immediately because of questions
and other kinds of questions that have
been raised with respect to to general
Flynn
there have been untidy administrations
in the past but usually it takes a while
to see these kinds of issues develop as
opposed to the coming in issues also to
have a campaign manager although
dismissed from the campaign with now
this bucket full of legal issues and the
ties to shall I say questionable people
in foreign places with strange-sounding
names I think it's completely unique
quantitatively I would have to honestly
go back and I'm serious about this and
look at the untidy administration of
ulysses s grant that administration got
into trouble fairly quickly because of
the just the emergence of corruption
corruption been an enormous problem in
the civil war enormous and it's one of
the reasons that honest Dave and I mean
that said we need a statue and it was
called the False Claims Act that really
goes after these very bad characters
well some of those very bad characters
found their way into government so I
don't know about quantitatively but this
is just it's it's terrible for the
country it's terrible for the country
when our presidents get into trouble at
what at whatever time if it's
self-inflicted then you just say well
they shouldn't have done this or doesn't
done that but I think I'll go ahead and
jump ahead and said I think we all hope
that Bob Muller gets to the bottom of
things
that the sort of intelligence committee
gets to the bottom of things and I'm
sure we'll chat about the what I see is
the confluence it's not just the Muller
investigation but it's what's happening
on Capitol Hill
and I'm so glad Richard mentioned
senator Sam Ervin because the
breakthrough in terms of the discovery
of the Watergate tapes came out of the
United States Senate well we're talking
about ethics and the law and as we know
what is unethical even patently
unethical isn't necessarily illegal do
you believe and let's stay with you for
a moment judge Starr do you believe that
Donald Trump at this point has done
anything that in your estimation would
be considered illegal or do you think
that this is just going to have to come
out in the wash over the course of what
still could be in many months and the
latter because I was very nervous so to
speak as a citizen to know that the
president ID States was having all these
interactions with the director of the
FBI that should not have occurred it's
not illegal but it's very unwise it's
very imprudent and then what was said in
those conversations we've had the
benefit a former director Comey's
testimony as to as to what happened I
listened very carefully that my own view
was and I'm pretty familiar with
obstruction of justice it didn't amount
to obstruction from what I heard from
what I heard but of course Bob Muller is
gathering the entirety of the evidence
and from that making the conclusions and
you know who to tell you know him
personally is he the man for the job and
absolutely there not be potentially sent
off by either Donald Trump or the
departments which ultimately would have
to do it well depending on the day it
would be a Saturday night massacre
because rod Rosen's died the Deputy
Attorney General was a person of total
integrity and so the president would in
this doomsday scenario have to fire
Rosen Stein because I don't think rod
would agree the Attorney General has
already recused himself so then it
becomes again the Saturday night
Massacre is not just the fall of
Archibald Cox we lost an attorney
general and a deputy attorney general
who had made commitments to the United
States Senate during their confirmation
that they would protect the Independence
of the then special prosecutor now we
called special counsel
and when I read the regulations of the
Department of Justice that guide the
exercise of judgment with respect to the
exercise to the appointment of a special
counsel I think if Donald Trump heaven
forbid
said he's got to go rod Rosen signed
would say I hereby resign and what's the
point the Senate Intelligence Committee
of the Senate Judiciary Committee and
there'll be another special counsel in
any event because the regulations and
I'm sorry but one last point the
regulations have the force of law but
they can be revoked in contrast to the
special prosecutor or independent
counsel provisions which were law passed
by Congress signed into law by the
president United States so they could be
rescinded but until they are by the
Attorney General they have the force of
law and while you were itching to make a
point well I just wanted to say that I
agree with Judge Starr and I think both
Judge Starr and and mr. Miller here
could tell us all just how long
investigations take before they uncover
their you know reveal their final
findings and so we can't rule out that
there's been a league allottee but we
can't know for sure yet and we should
keep an open mind as the facts are
developed but I think what we do know
and Judge Starr alluded to this is that
we've had some very significant
departures from the ethical and civic
norms of the executive branch and indeed
our country as a whole
and one of the problems with that is the
ethics laws in particular but also a lot
of our other laws were predicated on the
idea that there were certain norms in
place and so the laws factored in that
those are going to be followed when
they're not followed we suddenly
discover how completely vulnerable our
system is and so it begins with a
president who railed against his rival
for being connected to a not-for-profit
organization you know I agree with those
who say she would have had to resolve
that conflict of interest but again
we're talking
but a not-for-profit organization
suddenly we have a president retaining
an interest in a for-profit organization
that's not running around fighting AIDS
in Africa it's bringing in money
directly to that president that first
departure from our ethical norms set a
tone from the top that has now gone
trickling down through the
administration and I can tell you from
my dealings with them that it was night
and day dealing with this White House
and dealing with past White House's
and just to illustrate what things used
to look like I'll just give you one
brief anecdote Richard painter and I
were working on a nominee during the
Bush administration who was a very
high-profile nominee normally they're
not announced until we are done with all
of our work and we can say okay go ahead
and announce him and then you can send
him up to the Senate in this case there
was some real-time sensitivities there
was an event that the person had to be
at and so we got most of the work done
and were able to give the White House a
read saying we don't think there's any
showstoppers here so go ahead and
announce but we have to finish the
cleanup work and in one of the calls
with the individuals attorney afterwards
the attorney just gently pushed back on
one of the details as maybe an attorney
is getting paid by clients or do to test
the waters to see what the best deal
they could get for their client is and
all sudden ringing out across the phone
as Richard screaming your client doesn't
have to have this job and that came at
incredible cost to Richard because the
president had already stuck his neck out
and said he was going to handle you know
be nominating this individual and I
wouldn't have wanted to be in the room
if Richard went and said oh I I got rid
of your guy he's not going forward but
Richard took a strong stand and it
caused the attorney to immediately say
okay okay what do we have to do and
that's the minute when I learned what an
ethics official should really be and I
tried to live up to the standard that
Richard set but that was also the
culture because Richard knew for sure
that he had a president who care
about government ethics you may agree
with the policies and views of President
Bush or President Obama but I will tell
you both of those White House's were
extremely supportive of the government
ethics program and of OGE in particular
and the experience we're having now is
very consistent with a president saying
I can't have conflicts of interest I'm
just gonna keep my money and you know my
holdings and I'm gonna go to all of my
properties and I'm gonna announce you
know when I'm going there and bring the
press there and I'm gonna endorse
private companies solely because they
supported me and I'm gonna wear a hat
that I'm Hawking online while I'm
speaking at a hurricane disaster session
with the press and I don't think you
could paint a stoker contrast well Matt
that raises the point of whether the
president is above the law can the
president be above the law you were at
the Department of Justice where where do
you see this falling and how does that
contrast with the way that the DOJ was
able to operate and previous iterations
well theoretically he can't be above the
law but there are a number of laws that
he's exempt from and as we're finding
out as Walt just pointed out there are a
number of norms that presidents have
always adhered to in the past that
Donald Trump just doesn't care about and
I think the you know if you look at all
of them the one that that has always
worried me the most is the thing that
kind of prevents America from becoming a
Banana Republic and that is the
traditional independence of the Justice
Department this idea that no matter what
else happens the Justice Department
makes its own decisions about who to
investigate who not to investigate who
to prosecute who not to prosecute and
there's nothing in the Constitution
there's nothing in law there's nothing
in federal regulation that sets it up
that way
the president's theoretically could call
Attorneys General and say you know what
I want you to prosecute I want you to
lock up lock her up I want you to lock
up my former political opponent and
that's perfectly legal attorneys general
and presidents have always recognized
and especially in the post watergate era
that that is a that fundamentally for
the rule of law to have any meaning
needs to be removed from politics and
trump showed during the campaign with a
locker up chance during the transition
when he openly speculated about whether
Hillary could be
prosecuted whether she should not be
prosecuted and then through you know
their nine months in office that he
doesn't care about that in a theoretical
sense I don't think he ever was
seriously you know I don't think the
prosecution of Hillary Clinton was ever
something that was taken seriously by
him or by attorney general sessions but
also in a sense that really matters when
you have him asking the FBI director for
a loyalty pledge when you have him ask
asking him to back off an investigation
into his former national security
adviser and then when you have him
firing him you have the president firing
the FBI director when you won't do it it
it matters in a very real sense and I
suspect we are still going to find we're
still going to face one at least one
very big flashpoint before the end of
the Russia investigation where Bob
Muller is going to get too close to a
member of Donald Trump's family he's
gonna get too close to a member of the
President himself and the president is
going to force a Saturday night Massacre
type situation where he tried there with
centrist in the rules governing the
appointment of the special prosecutor so
he can fire him or whether he fires his
way down the Justice Department to do it
or whether he pardons everyone involved
in the case and it was going to it is
going to how we respond to that and
whether Republicans in Congress see that
as a red line is going to answer that
question of whether the president is
about the law or not well richer I'd
like you to weigh in on a point that
Matt brought up a moment ago which is
the idea of political norms that you had
presidents at least in modern history
who more or less would adhere to certain
standards there was sort of a John
McCain might say regular order of the
way the presidents would act both in the
campaign and also when in office and
that could be everything from how they
released their health care records to
how they released their tax returns we
we could mention a dozen one of them do
we need more laws does Congress need to
weigh in in a way that would effectively
take those norms take the ethical
standards and and codify them put them
into law I just think we need a sense of
decency I I don't think
bunch of rules I mean for example you're
not gonna have a rule saying that after
you won an election you don't keep
thrashing on the person you just beat in
the election whether or not she actually
won the popular vote I mean you just you
you actually do your job as president if
we had anyone in the bush White House
who was mouthing off about Al Gore or
John Kerry the way these people
including the president mouthed off
about Hillary Clinton we would have
fired him on the spot oh then this thing
that happened over there in Huntsville
two days ago I bet I looked at that is
this Huntsville Alabama in 2017 or
Nuremberg Germany in 1933 I mean this is
terrible you got people in a crowd
screaming like Iran and you think the
President of the United States would not
sink to the level of that type of person
in the crowd and then he said well you
talked to Jeff Sessions about that once
again he should be there to act
presidential and to talk about policies
if he's got a health care bill I haven't
heard about any actual proposals but
he's actually got a real health care
bill to propose instead of Obamacare
okay this is why what I want to do is
better talk about what he's going to do
for our country rather than this
thrashing on his opponent thrashing on
the media that's another thing that's
reminiscent out of what was going on
Germany in the 30s I know the President
Nixon didn't like the press that said a
bunch of stuff per ticket behind closed
doors but the constant ranting about the
media in the press we've never seen that
from an American president before and
then there's a lack of respect for the
United States Constitution the role
judges I mean we don't have so-called
judge the United States we got judges we
also don't have white charges black
judges Mexican judge we have judges and
he's not showing respect there and he's
not showing respect for the
anti-corruption provisions in the
Constitution and that includes
emoluments claus i know they'd like to
talk a lot of latin back when they
drafted the Constitution if we draft it
and Illinois where I was growing up
1970s they would have called the payola
clause but it's you know you know
foreign government profits or benefits
for anyone in the United States
government or the position of trust in
the United States government without the
consent of Congress and if he doesn't
agree with our view on their monuments
close you can go to Congress and work a
deal out with a Republican Congress but
I think they want to see his tax returns
and find out how many rubles are in
there but he's got to respect the
Constitution or he's not going to keep
this job but
but you know what do you really think
rich an I'm glad I don't have to follow
him next well Richard you might have
plenty of people some might say tens of
millions of people around the country
who voted for Donald Trump and said well
we knew exactly what we were getting
with Donald Trump all of America should
have known exactly what we were getting
with Donald Trump we voted for him
because we believed that he could make
America great again and you know what
he's running a different kind of
presidency than his predecessors we knew
that too coming in and he's now
president the United States what do you
say to the argument of let him be
President of the United States let him
do things a different way we elected him
to do it that way so who are we to say
that he can't now and they trusted him
just just like people bought those
nurtures and cocido bonds back in the
early nice but you know that doesn't
change the fact where the people aren't
getting paid it's pretty clearly didn't
do the job there and so you know I think
people voted for him believing that he
could make this transition and be an
effective president they did not vote
for him to come into office and
continually rant about the person he
defeated in the election they did not
vote for him to come into office and
ignore the environments Clause of the
Constitution they did not vote to have a
national security adviser who lied about
his contacts with the Russians I mean
the list goes on and on so people voted
for Donald Trump to be President in
accordance with the Constitution of the
United States not to be a king they
people did not vote to rescind the
Constitution and so once again he's
either got a the do his job accordance
to the Constitution or he's got to get
out of there good start did did Bill
Clinton in the late 90s or Donald Trump
in the late 2010 the situation overall
with their presidencies which one posed
a greater concern in your estimation for
for the country and and did one more so
than the other was a exit central crisis
I guess one could say well I'm my
mission was very specific and focused it
obviously grew
the sunrise for the Attorney General
United States Janet Reno but the
investigation started in 1993 yeah well
it actually had begun earlier it had a
long history but the point is that was
targeted what I think we're now telling
about as an ethos the biggest complaint
that I remember before I was appointed
as independent counsel was that there
was a sense of hubris a sense of
arrogance charming but nonetheless
arrogance illustrated by the firing of
the hapless seven career persons in the
travel office off with their heads
not a crime but not very pretty and
these were career civil servants who by
definition had served during Republican
and Democratic administrations poor form
a gentleman named Craig Livingstone was
brought in very early on to head the
White House Office of Personnel records
off with their heads so the heads who
were career people were sent packing and
Craig Livingstone and I have nothing
against Craig Livingstone but what was
his qualifications to be handling the
most sensitive information in the hands
in terms of personnel information in the
hands of the federal government he had
played Pinocchio at George Bush 41
campaign rallies he had dressed up as a
chicken at campaign rallies and so
what's his very first job to reward him
to the victor go the spoils so it was a
certain Jacksonian quality I thought and
a lack of respect for what we've heard
about here the traditional norms there
are certain functions even in the white
house that are best carried on by career
people who know what they're doing so I
think presidents would be well advised
to be and I think this is one of our
themes be aware of those norms be
respectful of those norms and even if
you've been brought in as a
transformational president
and a very narrow election losing the
popular vote quite handily by in three
million votes that suggests to me the
wisdom of let's build the coalition
let's reach across the aisle and so
forth and that's just not what we've
seen that's not what he intends to do
well I shouldn't say that look what he's
done recently but let's let's make a
deal and I was told by the way if you
read his and I haven't the art of the
deal you will understand him not getting
great Newt Gingrich's understanding
Trump just read his the art of the deal
he's here to make deals and that's all
the more reason he needs lots of lawyers
around him well do you see any parallels
between Bill Clinton at the vanguard of
being impeached and Donald Trump today
with being investigated or is that just
not a comparison that obviously easily
evidence the the impeachment went
forward really on the grounds of perjury
so has the president been under oath if
this president gets under oath and that
was very interesting one of the
fascinating things that we now
understand about the strategic decision
made by President Clinton in 1998 was
when there were revelations of this
relationship Dick Morris by his account
great brilliant guy who had advised
President he is a very brilliant guy
he helped orchestrate the re-election
campaign in 96 and so the president is
chatting with him this is all according
to Morris and the what did you do and so
forth and so he posed Morris posed two
questions in the overnight poll will the
American people forgive an extramarital
relationship the answer was yes
will the American people forgive perjury
the answer was no very interesting is
and when the entire episode unfolded and
it became clear that there were these
serious questions there was a huge
bipartisan cry for the president to
testify truthfully before the grand jury
and then what happened happened then I
think that if there had been a
resolution discussed - let's let's have
censorship plus with some kind of
punishment that I think thoughtful
people would have rallied around it
there was a formalistic sense it's
impeachment or nothing because Andrew
Jackson was censured and he went on as
before but I think that was what the
American people felt was an appropriate
response to what happened
that is even perjury which most people
thought was proven was insufficiently
related to the conduct of office so I
think that's one of the things to come
back to Donald Trump is his activity
does he commit some crime and it's a
question in the obstruction of justice
has looked at and if you look at the
charge of robert muller you'll see it's
perjury obstruction of justice
intimidation of witnesses what
constitutes intimidation so there gonna
be some very neat questions all this to
say don't you can say what you want to
on Twitter but if you're under oath be
very very cautious well Matt judge Starr
of course during the 90s was a
independent counsel and with that came
certain powers people of course may
remember the Starr report that came out
at the end of the work that you did
which laid out the case if you had made
does today 20 years or so later
does the Muller investigation have the
requisite tools to do a proper
investigation is this a bombshell
waiting to happen or is this something
because there will be no Muller report
because there is a difference between
what happened 20 years ago and today
this is something that it has the
potential to fizzle even if Donald Trump
does nothing at all in terms of
dispatching him I think the only way it
it fizzles would be if Bob Muller
completes his investigation
and finds that the president didn't do
anything wrong
in which case you know one of the things
about appointing someone like Bob Muller
so widely respected if he comes to that
conclusion I think there a lot of people
like me that would look at it and say I
agree that that's probably the right
outcome I trust Bob Miller to come to
that conclusion but there are a number
of ways this could end I know when when
Ken Starr was running his team they
looked at the question of whether the
president could be indicted and some
outside
scholars you recruited said yes there
were prosecutors on the special
prosecutors team during Watergate that
looked at the same question and said yes
I think that would be a it be a
difficult thing to accomplish in diving
the president it would raise all kinds
of constitutional questions would
ultimately go to the Supreme Court but
short of that you know Bob Muller can
write a report of his own at the end or
when you look at the tools he has
there's a Watergate precedent when Leon
Jaworski finished his investigation and
indicted a number of people which I
think it's pretty clear they're going to
be people that are indicted as a result
of this investigation
al manna for likely general Flynn he
named Richard Nixon is an unindicted
co-conspirator and then wrote a grand
jury report and with the judge's
approval turned that grand jury report
over to Congress over the impeachment
committee the Watergate committee and
that sort of became the basis it was
like the Star report wasn't a fishery a
report to Congress but sort of serve
that purpose so Muller has both you know
I think we all understand the
investigative tools that he has power to
subpoena the power of the grand jury but
he has a lot of tools at his disposal at
the end in terms of reaching conclusions
and if he decides that indictment isn't
the appropriate way for if he did do
things he decides the president violated
a law in his estimation but that
indictment isn't the way forward he has
a couple of different ways to put that
in the hands of Congress ante up the
question of whether they are willing to
you know take a look at those questions
and act and of course he could go on for
many months this all started really
around the issue of whether there was
any collusion with Russians be at Donald
Trump himself personally his family
members his campaign do you think that
the investigation should go forward in
different directions that
would be related to potentially but not
necessarily at the core of the original
purpose for for going forward with us if
you look at his original mandate it is
very broad it talks about any links
between the president or associates of
his campaign and the Russian government
that could include links from the
campaign it could also include links
from the president's financial dealings
if he had any dealings with the Russian
government or intermediaries it includes
any other matters that arise directly
from the investigation and I think Bob
Muller with rod Rosen Stein's approval
would interpret that is if I'm over
flipping up rocks about this and I find
something not related but that I see I
have the authority to go look at it and
then any obstruction of justice
questions that come up so he has a
number of you know I think he has a very
broad mandate and in terms of timing you
know typically the part of justice
investigations like this take a long
time
Bob Muller is not the kind of person
that lets grass grow under his feet and
if you look at the way he's moving
already
you know people there was a lot of there
were a lot of people surprised of how
aggressive he's been it to Paul Matta
for that FBI agents picked the lock and
showed up in his bedroom and woke him up
and that they're they're moving so
quickly with with threats of indictment
take a look at this from Bob Miller's
standpoint if you stop back you know we
kind of get a daily barrage of this
thing happens and this thing happens to
take take a step back and look at the
president's son had a meeting with a
Russian lawyer the pretext of which was
to receive information about how the
Russian government wanted to help elect
the president the president's campaign
chairman was overheard on intercepts
talking with either Russian intelligence
officials or intermediaries of Russian
intelligence officials the president's
national security adviser was overheard
on intercepts talking with the Russian
ambassador we don't know exactly about
what but enough that the the Department
of Justice thought it was inappropriate
and warned the White House the president
himself and his public statements can
best be described as being extremely
solicitous of the Russian government
so if you ask why is Bob Muller moving
so quickly and he's looking at this not
like a white-collar investigation but as
you know
a criminal enterprise and the taking it
like up you know a drug trafficking
enterprise this is in some ways the most
important investigation the Department
of Justice has ever conducted it goes to
the question of whether the president of
the United States himself has been
compromised by a foreign power you're
damn right he's moving it as
aggressively as he can and he's gonna do
it as quickly as he can
[Applause]
so well with everything mattress said as
a backdrop why did you leave in July
yeah well I put up as good a fight as I
could I think I had some wins and I can
talk about those but they started sort
of adapting to the strategies and I
reached the point where I didn't think I
could achieve more in there and when you
say adapting was there anything specific
that they did that really really made
you display this some of it's just the
sheer lack of transparency that the most
effective thing they did was cut us off
and for that I have to give you a little
brief background with presidential
nominees to the Senate for confirmation
oh gee he has a lot of leverage we we
were able to tell the nominees you're
not going to get a Senate hearing until
we finish the work with you so let's get
this all done and that was one of the
wins we had we used that a leverage that
leverage effectively and and I had to
really fight for it because the Senate
started threatening to have hearings
even without waiting for OGE to finish
and if they had done that we would have
lost our leverage so I wrote fairly hot
letters in in ethoxy terms hot there's a
certain decorum in Washington and I was
trying to stay within the norms but hot
within those norms to the Senate
committees and I sent that off there and
then I thought oh boy I hope this works
and it did they backed off and
rescheduled the hearings and we moved as
fast as we could to get those done and
as a result for a while you were seeing
ethics holding a little bit better out
at the agencies than at the White House
there's agency ethics officials on-site
their career people as Judge Starr said
the career people are invested in the
process and the system working
more recently the tone from the top
we've discovered is trickling down and
you've got these fabulous jet flights
with a sofa and a kitchenette and all
kinds of things from several cabinet
officials so we were effective there but
with the White House appointees they the
system is set up differently they come
into government we don't get their
financial disclosures first they're not
even due until they're in the government
for 30 days the White House can give two
45-day extensions they can then take
anywhere from 60 to 120 days before they
send their reports to OGE and so we
didn't have the chance to resolve
conflicts of interest and the White
House Ethics officials not only didn't
want to fulfill their responsibilities
in support of ethics they didn't know
how these guys just weren't competent to
do it and turned us down for training
and so when we finally started getting
these financial disclosure reports
trickling in and we're looking at the
potential conflicts of interest of the
White House officials we then asked the
White House to explain well what does
this a person do for a living or what
does that person do for a living all day
at the White House mums the word they're
not telling us and so they won't give us
information and I was in the position
where I was ultimately going to wind up
having to sign off on a financial
disclosure reports that were technically
compliant with disclosure rules as far
as I could tell but I had no information
about what the people were doing for a
living and I didn't want my signature of
vouching for these individuals and
saying they had no conflicts but the
biggest thing that was sort of the last
straw for me was when I fought a battle
for 30 days to get my hands on just the
most basic ethics records ogee has the
power to collect from within the
executive branch any kind of ethics
records and these were waivers I told
them released these secret waivers that
were hearing you're issuing and they
fought us and they actually had Mick
Mulvaney the head of OMB write a letter
to
and copy every single general counsel
and every single ethics official in the
government so it was a letter sent to
hundreds of people saying we don't think
you have the authority to collect this
well the thing is collecting documents
reviewing them is pretty much what OGE
does all day long so if we were out of
that business we could all just gone
home so I fought back really quite hard
on that and and ultimately prevailed and
got them to release these waivers as
late as Monday the week they released
him they were saying we're not going to
release them and then Wednesday they
released them I later heard from
somebody a rumor that Grassley's office
may have called over there I had quoted
something from Grassley at the end of
the letter where he had demanded that
the Obama administration release waivers
so I thought the language fit perfectly
here I put that in so I don't know if
that's true or not I don't know if
Grassley did call over there but in any
event they released them and the waivers
were unsigned undated most of them were
retroactive two of them were issued by a
person to himself and so the secret of
the secret waivers was that there were
no secret waivers they were just doing
whatever they wanted and then when they
got caught with their pants down they
had to scramble to gin up some waivers
and if you look at the metadata and I'm
it's pretty clear they worked on this
one for an hour and then this one and
then this one so they gin them up that
day and I thought good lord if these
guys are willing to essentially come one
step short of forging government records
there's not a whole lot more than OGE
with no investigative authority can do
in this job and that was pretty much the
thing that's sunk in on me after a while
and I thought there isn't gonna be more
I can do in this job well David April
the successor who's now leading og Eve
you described him recently using the
very technical term loosey-goosey when
describing his approach to ethics in
general do you feel that oh gee e is
diminished in the past couple of months
since you've left well it's relative
that term is one that he used himself
although he now denies it but just about
everybody who ever worked with him heard
him
himself that and so yeah I have some
concerns about what's going on there but
I balance that against the fact that I
don't know that anybody else could have
come in and achieved anything I'd been
doing this for a decade and a half and
applied every trick and tactic and
leverage that I could to get people to
follow the ethics rules oh gee he has a
lot of authority but no power and
authority for instances when the judge
issues an order but powers when the u.s.
marshals show up in your doorstep
because you didn't comply with that
order so we have the authority to demand
people do stuff but we didn't have the
power to back it up and so I don't know
that we'd be any worse off or any better
off if I was there or if anyone else was
there because in the end it comes down
to the only source of authority or power
og had again we had plenty of authority
was the White House counsel's office and
in the Bush administration I could rely
on Richard painter and all of the people
there and the Obama administration I had
lots of support and they truly proved to
me that ethics has no party I could
equally count on a Republican or
Democratic White House to be supportive
of the ethics program but the whole
program is predicated on OGE being able
to call the White House Council for help
and we would have cases where an agency
or an individual didn't want to do
something and we would try to work it
out and if we couldn't we'd call the
White House counsel's office and almost
invariably the next morning there'd be a
very nervous voice on the other end
saying what can I do for you and and
they would have really gotten a talking
to by the by the White House and they'd
be whipped into shape but in this White
House you know the message was OGE go
jump in a lake and we're not going to
support you and then all we have left is
going public and that was working for a
while but as they adapted by just
cutting us off on all information then
there was nothing to go public with and
although we could send demands for
documents and information we couldn't
send investigators marching in to go and
seize it
well one thing I have the authority to
do is open the session up to questions
from the audience so if you'd like to
line up there should be a couple of
micro
around for anyone who'd like we got
about 15 minutes left and well people
line up very quickly I'd love to get
from each panelist just to take there's
been some chatter on Twitter and I've
gotten some emails of people who knew
about this panel maybe watching it on
the livestream right now and so many
articulated in a different way what can
I do is a citizen of the United States
to to deal with any of the topics that
that we've discussed today people
expressing a lot of concerns that they
feel like they are marginalized in some
way or don't feel that their government
is representing them start with judge
Starr just very quickly move down the
line I think what they you just say -
you're a member of Congress in some
platform I believe in the rule of law no
one is with all of these basic
foundational principles and so would you
please do your job in terms of
supervisory hearings or encourage your
colleagues to do their job as a citizen
want no person to be above the law and I
can agree or disagree with a particular
policy but we should also agree
fundamentally that as we used to say in
the government
I hope they still do weird to turn
square corners you don't jaywalk okay
you don't walk against the light you say
even if I disagree with this law it is
the law until change we want a rule of
law administrations we want a rule of
law Congress right very quickly Richard
I think it's important that we respect
the truth and facts living in a world
where there is alternative facts we just
make up massacres out of whole cloth
Kellyanne Conway's so-called Bowling
Green massacre where the president
United States says his predecessor was
spying on him and then decides to accuse
the British as well I mean the list goes
on and on we should not tolerate in our
daily lives
anyone who can't tell the truth and we
should not politicize the truth
politically let's let Bob Muller get to
the bottom of the truth here and members
of Congress Republican and Democrat
should insist on finding out the facts
and that includes where the president's
get his money from for the Trump
Organization let's get the facts let's
get the tax returns and then we'll
figure out what to do but no more
ignoring the truth and no more lying and
I do not want to hear about one Merson
lying again about their contacts with
the Russians if you've done that in the
Bush administration you'd be in jail by
now
[Applause]
if there's one thing that every American
can do there's a bill that's been
introduced by two senators and their Tom
Tillis a Republican and Chris Coons a
Democrat to protect Bob Muller from
political interference and make it
impossible for the president to fire him
call your senator call your member of
the house call your Congressman and tell
them to support that legislation I think
it's the single most important thing
to ensure that this investigation goes
to its natural conclusion consistent
with what Matt just said I truly think
that the biggest threat were facing is
any threat to Bob Muller being fired
this is all that stands between us and
not having a country based on laws
frankly if we get to the point where
they do pull a Saturday night massacre
I'm going to be in the streets and I
hope every last person is
[Applause]
so let's start with my gentleman to the
left and before you start just to note
to anyone asking a question please ask a
question do not make a speech and in be
concise go ahead in order for the rule
of law have credibility we have to have
a robust due process and one of the
questions I have about what we're seeing
is that on the one side there seems to
be a dream team of lawyers with Moeller
and on the other hand we have lawyers
who are practicing outside of their
expertise and having public
conversations about private matters that
are privileged so going forward after
this what are your concerns to the the
executive given that it's not clear that
this is going to be a real fair fight
put it that way
I want to answer that because I think
that in our country we don't have equal
justice and that the folks with the most
money can hire the best attorneys and
get the best justice so if these guys
are hiring clowns who are sitting in a
cafe talking about their case and being
overheard that's inexcusable because
they are paying $1,500 an hour
talk about a fair fight the resources of
the billionaire that they're going after
far exceed any budget that Bob Muller
has so I think we do have a fair fight
because you've got very wealthy people
who can hire very good attorneys there's
also mechanisms for setting up legal
defense funds and I am not opposed to
legal defense funds as long as they're
done correctly and in compliance with
the laws and so I think that is the
answer is OGE needs to come out with
some new guidance on legal defense funds
and there's a whole story that we don't
have time to tell about why we don't
have that right now but they need to do
that I want to say one thing that a
number of these matters President Trump
is represented by the United States
Department of Justice at taxpayer
expense including on the emoluments
Clause cases and the three separate of
volume it's Clause cases about foreign
government money coming to President
Trump he is defended by the United
States Department of Justice they have
very good lawyers
over there they were not able to
persuade some of the best lawyers in the
country including kellyanne's Conway his
husband George Conway he wouldn't touch
that as that civil divisions yeah and
Richard you the crew has sued over the
suit we have sued over the Amaya's
clause in the United States Constitution
there two other lawsuits but those have
been defended by the Justice Department
they have good lawyers over there there
are some excellent lawyers who will not
take jobs working for Donald Trump I
wonder what but here they do have good
lawyers very good lawyers and the Civil
Division of the Justice Department and
were there second Donald Trump does have
some financial resources we don't know
what currency and what have much but I
know enough to think he's probably
ineligible to receive assistance from
the legal aid clinic at the University
so I think that he has the resources to
hire top-flight lawyers and yet I don't
know who these clowns are and number of
things I don't understand about them
including the mustache but anyway it's
his business so he wants to hire but
he's lawyered up a lot of her lawyer
Duff this is the most well-to-do a white
house we've had in decades
and so I don't really feel sorry for
them in terms of their access to high
quality legal services but you know some
really good lawyers don't want to work
for certain types of clients for example
those that go and tweet out something
it's exactly the opposite of what you
just said out there by half 24 hours
earlier I know that's why Kelly and
Conway husbands George I mean he
actually went on the Twitter and he said
you know mr. pros are you shooting
yourself in the foot so I think a lot of
these problems he's made he's brought
upon himself well let's move to the next
question we'll try to get as many
speakers in question Astor's as possible
please all right so my name is Sam I
just want to ask so it's a bit of a
speculative a question to all of you so
assuming that the investor investigation
is finished and the result you know
directly there's direct evidence of the
president you know being at fault and
God knows how many offenses do you think
the Republican Party
and both the House and the Senate will
have the moral gumption to stand up to
let's face it was gonna be a lot of
their base we're gonna be saying this is
the deep state this is fake news they're
just trying to take down the person
who's trying to make America great again
how do you think they're going to react
and if it's the worst-case scenario how
do we react I'll take it I think it
depends on two things one is how hot the
smoking gun is you know if it's
obstruction of justice I think that's
one thing because obstruction of justice
can you know it depends on corrupt
intent it can look different in the eyes
of the beholder
versus if it's you know outright
evidence that the president you know
knew about interference and in the
election and encouraged it I think
that's the first thing the second thing
and that's really it's it's a straight
political question is what's Donald
Trump's approval rating the day that
Muller produces such a smoking gun if
he's at 45% I think you'll see the
Republican Party excuse it justify it
and probably overlook it if he's a
twenty eight percent because he's
flailing about on other issues and he
started to drag them down then I think
it's a much different situation I've got
the five-minute warning so I'm not a
feels real quick and
as a Republican there got to be some
moral values here not just bunch of
opinion polls and you know if we can't
do something this administration there's
enough evidence already we don't need to
wait for Bob ball there needed to be
investigations at both houses of
Congress and if we don't get gone we're
going to be going the way other ways or
you might say the way of the New Jersey
generals in the United States Football
League it's gonna be a disaster and he's
going to take us down so it's our choice
I was going to make no one can match
Richard I was gonna make one point the
facts will drive this and just as in
Watergate President Nixon's very strong
support whether they liked him or not
had nothing to with likability when the
facts pointed in the direction of
structure obstruction of justice his
support collapsed when Charles Wiggins
of California said I'm now convinced
that at least for a period of time the
president estates engaged in an
obstruction of justice he resigned it
was over so I do not think there will be
a rallying around on partisan grounds
there will be just the facts what are
the facts and honestly so many of the
people who serve in the house
representatives all the acrimony they
are really good and honorable people and
they really want to do the right thing
as opposed to what do my constituents
want me to this is sort of a Burkean
moment you will be privy to the facts
and now we need your judgment right
please go ahead my name is Adam my
question is what can be done to restore
the broken ethics norms and what can be
done government wise to prevent them
from being broken again they're all
looking at me well it's all about tone
from the top and so I think we could fix
it tomorrow if the president woke up
turned over a new leaf and said I'm
going to divest all my assets I'm going
to stop
selling my goods I'm gonna stop doing
these things I don't see that happening
but what I'm very concerned about and
this goes to a question you asked
earlier about well should he just be
allowed to do whatever he wants to do
because people think they knew what they
were getting I don't think people knew
what they were getting because I don't
think this issue was explored I think
partly the media's to blame because they
didn't think he would win so nobody
thought about how he would deal with it
if he won but my big concern is is this
the new norm and the longer it persists
the more at risks becoming a norm and a
lot is going to be on the shoulders of
the next president and what we're at
danger of is let's say that Democrats
put up somebody fairly unsavory and they
say well he got away with it so you
can't question me about it and they'd be
right but we need somebody of good moral
fiber to say that was wrong
and I'm going to self impose a level of
structure on my behavior that restores
norms then this could just be an
aberration and so whether it's a
Democrat or a Republican I hope whoever
comes next says I am reinstituting these
norms through my own behavior and I
challenged the press to pose that
question specifically to each candidate
during the primaries will you stand up
to restore the ethical character of our
executive branch
you'll have to be the last question so
make it a good one
oh god no pressure okay so if you know
the investigation basically concludes
something you know the worst and it is
undermines the legitimacy of a trump
presidency right and he ends up being
shown the door what is that what does
that say to the legitimacy of a pentas
presidency who wrote in on that you know
illegitimate wake or O'Ryan presidents
there are anywhere down the line of
succession so what does that do to the
legitimacy of the office of the
President
domestically internationally and how do
we move forward from that I'd like all
the panelists to address it keep in mind
that your answers stand in between now
and happy hour so let's start with well
why don't we start in reverse lookup so
it comes back to it we shorted a minute
so I think the first the the first thing
is it depends on what Mike Pence did if
anything he seems to be strategically
absent from a lot of important pieces
which is you know not not unwise on his
part but look I think when Donald Trump
leaves whether it's because he leaves
before the at the end of his term or
when it's it's it's because he's not
reelect ador he serves two full terms
the next president is Walter is going to
have an or an enormous repair job to do
in this country it's not just repairing
adherence to all the things we've been
talking about norms and ethics and rule
of law it's this common sense of decency
it's not picking fights with NFL players
on Twitter and so you know I disagree
with probably just about everything Mike
Pence believes in but I have to think
that you know Mike Pence would you know
approach just the the common basic
questions of how a president oughta
behave differently than Donald Trump
does I'll volunteer to go next so I
don't go after Richard
exactly I think to answer that question
as Matthew just modeled you have to go
content-neutral on the political beliefs
of the individual and so if we step away
from the political views of Mike Pence
or Donald Trump and our concern right
now is about Donald Trump's behavior
there are those who will fault Mike
Pence for having been complicit in the
sense that he was his vice president but
I think what I could tell you is that
I've met with both the attorneys in the
White House counsel's office and the
attorneys in Mike Pence's office when
they came over to do the financial
disclosure forms and so forth and I
would describe the attorneys in the
White House as circus clowns and the
attorneys in Mike Pence's office as real
old-fashioned government attorneys they
have particular political beliefs but if
we look at this content-neutral this is
an individual who has served in
government who's been part of government
who has a staff full of people who are
consistent with the government culture
in terms of their language that they
speak in the end there and their
behavior so I think that if we set aside
the politics and look only at the
behavior of the two I think that if we
had a Mike Pence presidency people could
argue over the policies and the politics
and have very strong views as Matt
suggested but I think we would be
dealing with more of a traditional
presidency where the question is are you
are you freaked out by a candidates
views or do you agree with the
candidates use but you're not concerned
about the container being damaged in the
container being the institutions of our
representative form of government say
the Miller investigation involves just
the question of whether crimes have been
committed I mean he is a special
prosecutor and his job is to prosecute
crimes there are many other issues that
fall outside of the scope of his
investigation that I'm very worried
about and that Americans ought to be
worried about and the
Congress ought to be worried about
everything from the foreign government
payments and violation of the monuments
clause which is not a crime this
business going back and forth with a
leader of North Korea acting like two
schoolchildren and an argument and
they're both playing with nukes I mean
this is extremely dangerous situation a
president who has said at least on the
campaign trail and is not backing off at
the knees don't exclude people from
entering the United States based on
their free exercise of religion a flat
violation of the First Amendment I mean
the list of problems goes on and on much
of this is far outside the scope of the
Muller investigation but we need to have
a Congress that is playing an active
oversight role as contemplated by the
Constitution we need bank balances of
power on this country that they're not
doing their job they're gonna have to
get fire than members of Congress I mean
that's the next big decision he's been
made and I'd like to see more
Republicans on there but they got to be
Republicans they're doing their job not
just sitting on their can and this is
not working my view is that the American
constitutional system is wonderfully
resilient your question brought to mind
the election of James Earl Carter jr.
and in looking at what has happened over
the last four years or the eight or
eight years the American people tend to
respond to voices that say that was then
we need a new day but under our
constitutional order and the brilliant
thing about Jimmy Carter's campaign it
was governor of what was view then
viewed as very small stayed in the south
was it I will never lie to you so
there's a hunger for truth and honesty
in government that same hunger gave us
the Ethics in Government Act of 1978
with these various and sundry provisions
that we've been talking than we've been
talking about so I would say have
confidence in the flexibility of the
constitutional order but also the basic
goodness of the American people and with
that everyone is welcome to go to the
ATM
Center and please give a round of
applause for battle
thanks for joining us